[Música]
los labios rojos un corte de pelo
cuadrado flequillo negro una silueta
fácilmente reconocible que se convirtió
lo que no es de extrañar en el símbolo
de su marca chantal thomass tras varias
décadas en la industria de la moda
la diseñadora decidió subastar 650
piezas de su archivo la primera vez que
eran mis hijos con eso cuando yo ya no
esté y la segunda vez que también quería
mostrar sed porque ahora sólo se me
conoce por la lencería toledo así que
quería mostrar que también había hecho
moda cuando durante mucho tiempo durante
unos 30 años y que había hecho cosas
bonitas de las que soy bastante
orgullosa yo quería mostrar esas cosas a
principios de los años 70 cuando aún no
tenía 20 años chantal thomass creó su
primera empresa la llamita en hampton en
aquella época revolucionaria la moda
necesitaba una renovación con el impulso
del empresario pierre y la cámara
sindical de alta costura modernizó la
profesión abriéndola a nuevos talentos
se los llamó los jóvenes diseñadores en
ese momento tenía
de buenos amigos con jean-charles de
castelbajac y pienso que esa generación
quería acción tenía ganas de vestirse
diferente o una tendencia de jamón por
ejemplo hubo años en los que el color
era el marrón
así que bueno todas las chicas se
vestían de mar bajo nuestra generación
tiene la montana sonia queríamos atrás
conocido por su uso
así que hicimos prendas que nos parecían
más jóvenes y más contemporáneas y
diferentes roja donde queríamos algo
diferenciados
en los años 70 80 90 los desfiles de
moda que podían durar hasta 45 minutos
tres veces más que ahora eran un caos
alegre un desorden acogedor la imagen de
la moda aún no estaba estandarizada los
fotógrafos se apoyaban en la pasarela
las modelos se divertían entre ellas
estaban claudia schiffer karen mulder
christy turlington adriana karembeau eva
herzigova naomi carla bruma wisin era
una fiesta era una fiesta pasábamos
noches y noches preparando estos
desfiles trabajando hasta las 4 de la
mañana éramos un grupo de jóvenes que
nos conocíamos todos escondes y vamos a
ver los desfiles de los demás no había
rivalidad ya ve porque cada una tenía su
propio estilo de comenzadas y la unión
ya tenía su propio estilo o sea yo yo a
ver a cloud montana a thierry mugler y
de gonnet éramos amigos salíamos juntos
por la noche una íbamos de fiesta juntos
gramos cercanos hablemos de estilo y un
ejemplo de su estilo
ese es el lado masculino femenino o sea
son telas de traje de hombre siempre me
ha gustado la sastrería más pero
efectivamente detrás
use una levita de fracking
al día está totalmente forrada de
volantes hola es una tela masculina una
tela de oro cómo llego a la lencería la
lencería vino después dos hits más de
hecho hecho en señas mi generación era
una generación que no quería usar
sujetador es ser instrucción autónomo
porque todos simplemente eran
sujetadores de mamá y entonces me dio
símbolos de qué lástima que no haya
cosas bonitas ricomalillo y no tengamos
lencería fashion entonces encontré un
fabricante en lista dura y le mandé
hacer unos ligueros en telas que eran de
la moda que no eran las clásicas cenas
de los faltadores que en ese entonces no
había ligera todavía
y entonces la lencería era mucho menos
cómoda así que intenté con los jerseys
con las prendas de punto hacer cosas que
fueran espectaculares y casi de hecho de
moda que la gente quisiera ponerse como
para darse el gusto de usar un sujetador
bonito sin él creo que como yo era de
una generación que no usaba sujetadores
porque eran feos se pusieron de moda muy
rápidamente la moda de la lencería la
lencería de fantasía fontes y original
nada tuvo éxito bastante rápido pero en
abril de 1999 esta feminidad
tremendamente extravagante provocó un
escándalo en las vitrinas de las
galerías lafayette chantal thomass
exhibió modelos reales
las asociaciones feministas se
manifestaron a los gritos de la fire
proxeneta protestaban contra la
mercantilización de los cuerpos
la imposición de modelos sexistas
entonces actualmente cuáles son sus
aficiones mesón de tejas en mis
aficiones fueran
bueno por ejemplo ordenar mi archivo ya
que tenía tiempo tenía todas estas
prendas que había guardado bueno tres
cuartos mucha mucha noche así que
organicé de todos estos archivos
verisign de hoy para volver a encontrar
los años de los vídeos de los desfiles
para encontrar bueno es un verdadero
trabajo
hace mucho tiempo en eso y bueno ahora
tengo una vida familiar tengo nietos
viejos tengo algunas cosas que hacer en
el extranjero también colecciones
cápsulas de vez en cuando es agradable
simio aquel abrigo de marabú y plumas de
avestruz que llevaba isabelle adjani
cuando recibió el césar a la mejor
actriz en 1984 por verano asesino de
jean becker vendido en marabú también
aquella falta crinolina y suéter de
manga corta vendida a que el corsé
bolero minifalda de crin negro adornado
con un cordón de satín negro vendido
sólo quedarán los recuerdos estos no
tienen precio